the other occasion of archimedes it is must be new around he was an ancient greek never met him
swept america first it was san francisco up till then just a sleepy town on the pacific ocean
discovered in nuggets is ostrich eggs honest open arms if you renounce worldly goods and riches
earn your bread by the sweat of your proud tin pan it'll be ten dollars ten dollars that's
robbery for a tin pan twenty dollars but it was ten dollars just now coming very rare yes in a few
days san francisco was turned into a ghost town only twelve people remained you see the town's
been deserted everybody's off looking for fortune i may as well go as well trouble is i have this
store it's time i did a good deal i mean a good deed i'll buy your place for fifty dollars all
right fifty dollars that isn't really much huh there are no sales so how much is it worth
Yes, well, I suppose you're right.
Yep.
I suppose you've got the pan that you'll need.
No, I don't.
Here you are, and that'll be $50.
It'll be wiped out.
Too bad, but this is the last pan.
Fever spread all the way to the East Coast.
Everybody wanted to make a fortune in the gold fields.
Rich, poor, clerks, priests, they all headed west,
leaving jobs and family, chasing a golden dream.
I don't want to go so far away.
We have a nice life right here.
Manhattan, why leave?
I'm going because no man's given an opportunity to get rich twice.
I'm going to build you our dream home with gold.
You'll be able to satisfy your every dream.
You deserve all the good things of life.
Be sure to unpack all those shoes, Jack, and put them on display.
Oh, I'm sorry, sir. No time.
I'm going right now to California to find gold.
You're my best salesman. How can I let you go?
Well, I understand. The truth is, sometimes I dream of going out to California to find gold.
Come on, we only live once.
I'm going with you, Jack, and my wife will run the store while I'm going.
Read 'em and weep.
You fellas here, there's gold in California. Go get it!
I'm a gold rush too. Well, it wouldn't be the same without me.
With my boat, you're guaranteed a pleasant trip and you will be in California in three months.
More like three times three months.
And you want how much?
Only $600, meals not included naturally.
I'll take you to Panama in my clipper, just $500. You walk a little way in no time on the Pacific.
You take my second clipper and for $500 all the way to California...
Here's what I'll do. In a real wagon, you can trace the paths of the pioneers at a modest price. $600 cash.
Well, what do we do? Do we take his wagon?
Mr. Williams, I'm going to California and look for gold.
When I'm rich, I'll build a nice house, buy livestock, and if you give your consent, marry your daughter, Sarah.
No point going away. No, not for that. You don't need gold.
Ah, thanks, but I want to try my luck. I'm young, and it's now or never.
Well, then take my best horse for the journey, and good luck to you. I hope you strike it rich.
I just got here. I'm from Oregon Way.
Hello. It was Fred. I'm from Manhattan, myself.
I believe that my claim is right besides your claim.
Come on. We'll fence it in, like I did for my claim.
Then I'll show you how to pan for gold.
It's pretty back-breaking, all right.
But you believe me, it's worth it when you find it.
There's a good vein here.
I've already panned about $50 worth.
Two or three good months, I'll be returning.
Go back home.
I suppose you've got plans?
Well, I'm not married yet, but I'm engaged to a girl named Sarah.
I see. You're a new neighbor. I don't suppose you'd care to relax and play a little poker. What do you say, huh?
Not playing. I might lose everything in one game.
Me? I'm going to have a look around. Maybe I might be lucky.
Some news! Show me a new invention. You pan go quicker.
It's a steak this big. Say, let's go!
Folks coming in from all over? It's not so surprising people filling up the whole town, huh?
Look, a hotel, a saloon, a restaurant, gambling hall, food shops, jailhouse, more restaurants.
That place was there before, but it's much bigger now.
Specter's paradise.
Mine's the best liquor store in San Francisco, and I got the finest whiskey in the West.
The tenderest steaks in all of California.
Two pounds apiece, only six dollars, cheap at half the price.
Then I soak my bread first, and then I take a good whiff of your cooking steaks, that's all.
You're in no right to smell my steaks for free.
Pay me half a dollar right now.
Ha! Meld your steaks and you heard my money clink. The way I look at it, we're square.
He's right, you're square. Now leave him alone.
Hey, the old guy's pretty smart, isn't he?
Get our hot bat there. Sounds good to me.
Steaks only a pound each, or real ones are three pounds.
We want the real ones.
Isky?
No water.
Water's good to wash with, but not too often.
That's what I call a pretty woman.
But remember, it was in 1849 now, and out of a total population in San Francisco,
There were only 15 women present.
That's enough looking at her.
Now look at what I want and when I want.
Listen, who are you to tell me what I could look at it?
Easy to see that she's going to cause trouble, that one there.
Self-defense.
No matter when I hear a pistol shot, there I am ready to help out.
Do you work the funeral at $30 or $60?
Oh no, the $30 special will do.
To carry him, I will need your help.
Got the wrong body over there.
This is the one you want.
Take a good look around.
It's a great time.
Cities are mushrooming all over.
They're building everywhere. 25 million Americans won't be long.
25 million? Maybe you're exaggerating some.
25 million.
3 to 1.
Betsy wins, I win. But if it's Calaveras that wins, you lose.
Is it a bet?
Yeah, you bet.
You're still young, and like every youngster, it takes time to settle down. I'm sure you all agree.
Win them.
If there's a letter for you, it'll cost you $1.
No wondering when I'm going to be coming back home.
What's your news?
It's a letter from Sarah. She's beginning to miss seeing me.
Anyway, I'm beginning to miss her.
I'd like to go back.
Anything you want.
Just broke our shovel.
Where is everything?
Oh, I mean, all of your stock.
Well, there you are, one shovel.
You won't find a better one.
And how many do you want?
One, two, three?
Hey, he's beginning to miss me too much.
Maybe I'll go back that way.
Vane's about played out.
Not much gold lately.
I'm thinking of Sarah waiting back there, thinking of me.
I've enough gold now to buy a farm and livestock.
Then you'll ask Mr. Williams if you can marry his Sarah.
Well, now look, you're both good fellas.
So let me give you a little piece of advice.
An eye on your goal day and night.
I've got a feeling that there might be a few crooks around who just might be interested.
Well, partner, so long and good luck.
So long.
Thanks.
Let's check.
I'll go take a look.
$10,000 each of us.
That's about right.
Pretty, isn't it, Pete?
It sure is.
You're right.
It's time to go.
Okay, Pete, but we're going to miss each other, I bet.
That's for sure.
This movie and art claim is ours, you claim stick.
Come on.
You accusing me?
Are you saying it?
Was me who moved him?
Choose me of robbing.
Go ahead.
You go, listen, I've got a...
Always comes up with good ideas.
Pretty sure it's done.
We can put the plan into action now, right?
Right. It's now or never.
Came to bring you a gift.
A small token of our gratitude.
Want to thank me, you say?
What for? I don't understand.
Why are you thanking me?
For returning our sacks of gold.
Yeah, we worked pretty hard to get it.
Lucky thing, one of your men was so nice, he gave it back.
Thank you.
We brought you a roast pig. It'll be mighty tasty.
It's around a campy two gays. Take them. They're right here.
Pessengers off to make a fortune, but the other way, they don't have many.
We'll make you a special price. $200.
We'll leave tomorrow afternoon.
Don't worry. I'll be aboard, Captain.
I don't think we'll be needing this anymore.
As well, try to sell it.
Nothing. We'd like to sell some back.
All first class. We struck it rich with this stuff.
For the lot.
Charges over $80.
This may profit margin.
It is precisely what I'm needing to pick up gold pieces, but if I'm calculating correct, it's not cheap.
I might even go so far as to say you are robbing me.
We'll sell you the same stuff.
How much?
Just $20, naturally in cash. What do you say, mister?
Say yes, you have an honest face.
Let's spend the 20 on a good meal.
Two three-pound steaks and an apple pie.
Subsidials for both of them.
$60 or $100 unforgettable experience funeral.
Well, 200 left on the table, well, they will be buried in style.
Good trip home.
Bye, Fred.
Good luck.
Be shoveling off to each his own.
Right, partner?
You've seen for yourselves what it must have been like back in the gold rush.
Some excitement, some tragedy.
Life was very hard, and often bandits would come and try to rob a man of many years' work.
They were all there, farmers and sales clerks and highborn and lowborn and all chasing a dream of riches and gold, you know.
They created a new lifestyle, new society.
We can't admire all of them. There were plenty of bad ones. Those bandits, poker cheaters. Come on, admit I'm right.
Yes, you're right. But what do you expect? As my ancestors said back then, it was a new young country and settling down takes time.
That's how it was. California would join the Union in 1850 and just ten years later would begin a terrible civil war with brother against brother.
And it would almost rip the country apart and leave a bitter taste for generations.